would it surprise you if i said the rich
the one percent pay 40 of all taxes in
america interesting what surprised me
yeah yeah really interesting it's a
little a little more fair than you might
have thought yeah
what percent of income do you think the
top one percent pay i think they're
paying like freaking two percent of them
they're paying 27
what 27 what percent of their income do
you think people at the 50 and below
pay
probably higher than 27 percent it gets
higher the lower your income comes was
the way the number is i think it's
probably over 50. it's four percent oh
wow
interesting
i love that interesting is the code word
for i'm an idiot that is interesting hmm
i mean i'm still gonna vote for all the
same politicians who've been lying to me
and i'm still gonna say next time
somebody asked me on the street that the
rich should pay more taxes but it is
interesting that you're completely
exploding my worldview with like one
sentence